Jorah Mormont: When the Doom claimed Valyria,
the great freehold fractured into warring
cities and upstart nations ripe for the taking.
Out of the east swarmed the Dothraki, the
horselords of the plains who feared only defeat
and dragons, and now the dragons were all
gone.
Under the great Khal Temmo, they sacked and
burned every town and city in their path.
No army could stand against them, because
the Dothraki do not stand.
The horselords do not draw up battle lines
or hide behind shield walls or layer themselves
in armor.
The Dothraki charge.
Their blades are more scythe than sword, and
better to cull the infantry ranks without
breaking stride.
Even their archers fire from horseback so
that advancing or retreating, the arrows never
cease.
To the Dothraki, a man who does not ride is
no man at all, without honor or pride.
When the city of Qohor realized Khal Temmo
was coming, they strengthened their walls,
doubled their own guards and hired two full
companies of sellswords.
The Dothraki were used to glorified farmers
with spears; Qohor would show them a proper
army, with armored and mounted cavalry to
match the horde's own.
As an afterthought, the city leaders sent
an envoy to Astapor to buy Unsullied.
The slavers had always claimed that the Unsullied
were the great Ghiscari legions come again.
Few cared.
The dragon-burned ruins of Old Ghis were a
stark reminder that the age of the foot-soldier
was over.
The envoy had his orders, however, and quickly
bought three thousand Unsullied for the long
march back, for Unsullied do not ride.
But while they marched, Khal Temmo arrived
at Qohor.
I can imagine how pleased the Khal was to
finally face a challenge.
By the end of the battle, crows and wolves
feasted on what remained of Qohor's heavy
horse.
All the sellswords had fled.
Qohor knew that the Dothraki would very soon
break through the gates to slave and burn
at their pleasure.
Yet the next day Khal Temmo woke to find before
the gates three thousand eunuchs in formation,
armed with only spears, shields and spiked
helms.
The Unsullied had slipped past the Khal's
army in the night while the Dothraki feasted.
Khal Temmo had many times their number and
could easily have flanked the small forces,
but to the Dothraki, men on foot are made
only to be ridden down.
Eighteen times the horselords charged and
eighteen times the Unsullied locked their
shields, lowered their spears and held the
line against twenty thousand Dothraki screamers.
When the Khal's archers rained arrows on them,
the Unsullied lifted their shields above their
heads until the swarm passed; and then they
held the line.
In the end, only six hundred Unsullied remained,
but more than twelve thousand Dothraki lay
dead, including Khal Temmo and all of his
sons.
The new Khal led the survivors past the city
gates where one by one each man cut off his
braid and threw it down before the feet of
the Unsullied, defeated and shamed forever.
Since that day, the Unsullied fill the ranks
of cities and households wealthy enough or
desperate enough.
Sellswords fight for gold, knights for glory
and Dothraki for blood.
To a man, the Unsullied fight only to obey.
With the right master over them, imagine how
the forces of chaos would break against their
shields.
The conquerors, the madmen, the usurpers.
Between the Free Cities and the Bones, between
the Shivering Sea and Slaver's Bay, spreads
the Dothraki Sea.
Named not for its waters but for how freely
its conquerors roam upon it.
A traveler on the Dothraki Sea will find few
villages and no farms.
Because the Dothraki view it as a sin to cut
into their Mother Earth with plows and shovels.
And the Dothraki know only one punishment.
The closest the Dothraki approach to civilization
is Vaes Dothrak.
Though to outsiders, it doesn't look like
a city.
There are no walls because the Dothraki believe
only cowards hide behind them, instead of
facing an enemy blade in hand.
But the Dothraki couldn't do that here either.
Within the bounds of the city, no one, not
even the mightiest Khal, may carry a blade,
by order of the priestesses of the Dosh khaleen.
Not that any enemy would be foolish enough
to attack the sacred city of the Dothraki
in the first place.
Two giant bronze stallions rear over the entrance
to the city, their hooves meeting in the air
to form an arch, the famous Horse Gate.
Through it is the Godsway, where the Dothraki
drag the sacred idols of the cities and peoples
they've broken.
Along one side, stone gods look down on you
from cracked thrones with chipped and stained
faces, their names lost to time.
Across the road, monsters watch you pass.
Black iron dragons with jewels for eyes, roaring
griffins, manticores with barbed tails poised
to strike and other terrible beasts from every
corner of Essos.
But there is nothing to fear.
If these gods and devils had any power, they
would never have ended here.
Not all foreign gods in Vaes Dothrak are broken.
In the Eastern and Western Markets, merchants
worship their god of trade with the sufferance
of the Dothraki, who themselves don't understand
buying and selling.
The Western Market is a great square of beaten
earth filled with animal pens, drinking halls
and a maze of stalls and crooked aisles.
Even goods from Westeros find their way here.
Though the merchants who sell them wouldn't
know a Lannister from a Frey.
The Eastern Market is, fittingly, a stranger
place.
The elders of the Dosh khaleen view it with
suspicion and most Dothraki stay away.
They aren't wrong.
The great elephants, the basilisks in silver
cages and the striped black-and-white horses
of the JogosNhai are harmless enough.
But I can see how the elders wouldn't want
their younger members to see the warrior maids
of Hyrkoon, who wear iron rings in their nipples
and rubies in their cheeks.
Or listen to the Shadow Men, who cover their
bodies with tattoos and hide their faces behind
masks and whisper dark secrets for a price.
This is all of Vaes Dothrak that foreigners
ever know.
For only Dothraki are permitted in the inner
city where the Dosh khaleen live out their
lives.
A bloodrider, drunk on fermented mare's milk,
once told me that the Dosh khaleen are stewards.
They prepare for the day when every rider
of every khalasar shall return to the city.
And the Dothraki truly will be one blood and
one khalasar again, under the greatest Khal
of all, the Stallion Who Mounts the World.
He will ride to the ends of the earth and
grind nations into dust, and take the whole
world as his herd.
Or so the prophecy goes.
Yet the world is vast, with many places a
horse can't go.
The Stallion Who Mounts the World couldn't
rear above a mountain range.
Or leap across the sea.
Still, the world has been conquered before.
Just not with stallions.
The Doom took Valyria in minutes.
But the rest of Essos wasn't so lucky.
Out of the east swarmed the Dothraki.
And there were no dragons to push them back.
The Dothraki tide slammed first into the Sarnori,
who called themselves the Tall Men, and whose
ancient kingdom dominated the grasslands of
Essos.
The Tall Men at first scorned the Horselords
as uncivilized barbarians.
Which they were.
But Khal Mengo had united all of them into
one khalasar with one aim.
To trample the world beneath their hooves
and take other peoples as their herd.
One by one, the cities of the Tall Men were
overwhelmed.
Still, they wouldn't unite against the Dothraki.
Many didn't believe the tales of the rare
survivors.
No army could move so fast or strike so quickly.
They didn't know that the Dothraki live in
the saddle and have such command over their
horses that they seem to have four legs, not
two.
Where most archers fire from foot, the Dothraki
fire from horseback.
Charging or retreating, it makes no matter;
they are just as deadly.
But the Dothraki prefer close combat, howling
for blood as they ride down their enemies
with their arakhs.
And there were so many of them.
When Khal Mengo's son, Khal Moro, laid waste
to the Waterfall City of Sathar, renaming
it "The Place of Wailing Children," the Tall
Men finally realized their peril.
Led by a High King, they assembled a great
army to break the khals once and for all and
met the Dothraki on what would ever after
be known as the Field of Crows.
The four khals commanded almost 80,000 horsemen
between them.
The Tall Men had 100,000 foot soldiers, 10,000
armored riders, 10,000 light horsemen, and
6,000 scythed chariots.
As battle was joined, the earth-shattering
advance of the Tall Men's chariots smashed
through the center of the Dothraki horde,
the spinning blades on their wheels slicing
through the legs of the Dothraki horses.
When one khal went down before them, cut to
pieces and trampled, his khalasar broke and
fled.
The chariots thundered after the fleeing horsemen,
and the High King and his armored riders plunged
in after them, followed by their foot soldiers,
waving their spears and screaming in victory.
But it was a trap.
The Dothraki were not fleeing, as the Tall
Men realized when the Horselords suddenly
turned their horses and unleashed a storm
of arrows.
Two more khalasars swept down on the Tall
Men's flanks while another attacked them from
the rear, cutting off their retreat.
Completely encircled, the High King and his
mighty host was destroyed.
The Tall Men had stood for thousands of years.
Now the crows feasted on their corpses, as
the Dothraki squabbled over their valuables.
The common wisdom is that the Dothraki tide
finally broke upon the spears of the Unsullied
at Qohor, saving Essos from the Horselords.
In truth, the days when the Dothraki could
threaten the entire world had already passed.
The great khalasar forged by Khal Mengo had
splintered into a dozen hordes after the death
of the last great khal, and the riders had
resumed their petty feuds.
The grasslands of Essos are now called the
Dothraki Sea, but no more nations drown in
it.
Still, the Dothraki priestesses, the Dosh
khaleen, prophesy that one day the Dothraki
will gather at Vaes Dothrak, their holy capital,
and unite once more under the greatest khal
of them all, the Stallion Who Mounts the World.
He will lead their people to the ends of the
earth and grind all nations to dust beneath
them.
I knew a khaleesi who the priestesses said
would give birth to this Stallion.
She didn't.
No doubt, the Dosh khaleen have made the same
prophecy before and will again.
World conquest is an alluring dream, but few
who dream it ever awake to its reality.